[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je rêvais décennies j'en ai vu des
entiers de merde
vas-y je suis sean connery
[Applaudissements]
attendez je vais faire un jogging
j'avais même ramené james bond girl
[Applaudissements]
si vous me défoncer moi ce sera jean
michel maire non ouais sûr et certain
mehdi direct moi je suis sûr de moi il
est gentil et serviable
c'est sûr qu'ils me ramènerait le petit
le petit a jolly cette grève parce que
s'ils ramènent le petit lait c'est que
générallement c'est papon quand même des
gens ici monsieur gens pour leur dire
merci
oui çà çà çà çà bien marié ça c'est une
technologie qui vient du mexique les
fous d'habitude chacun vous êtes tous
par exemple sont chez elles ou
mademoiselle k la porte avions uss à 0 à
clarens à côté de montpellier a compté
montpellier à côté merci alors quel est
ton animateurs préférés alors j'hésite
entre mon ami arthur est mon ami cyril
de faire un prix parce que tu sais que
c'est tombé et le monde attend que
j'aime beaucoup laurent roger beaucoup
aux tic gens et mouloud aussi qu'on a
aussi nadège chambon honda new look est
fou de toi on a les mêmes mots simone
qui fait passer pendant mon 4 aussi
alors tu as cité arthur et moi donc j'ai
besoin de savoir que celle qui
l'incitent g dans ton coeur pour cela je
vais te donner des situations à toi de
me dire qui tu choisis en quartz tu vois
qu'en bas de la rue il y a deux colosses
qui t'attendent visiblement ils ne sont
pas là pour te demander à celle-ci pour
t'accompagner préserver la sécurité du
choisi arturo acuna
je pense que dans certains cas tu peux
être un petit peu belliqueux alors je
choisis
[Musique]
dieu
c'est con à l'antenne c'est pas vrai
merci à michel castaldi
et racontent leur ville tranquille
oui
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel je sais vous aviez deux
passions vous avez deux passions dans la
vie vous aviez de rêve des nouveaux
cheveux et une trottinette je sais que
vous voulez ça pour leur anniversaire
les cheveux c'est fait eh bien regardez
j'ai allier les deux c'est pour vous
regarder
[Applaudissements]
gemalto nous
je vais sac à dos d'homme c'est vraiment
mon cadeau de là un autre gars sont bien
nos gars sont qu'un petit message pour
vous regardez c'est rené malleville
qu'un petit mais ça aujourd'hui
j'apprends que c'est la nuit la terre de
mon meilleur ennemi jean michel maire
alors tu vois je passais outre tout tout
et outrages envers moi bon anniversaire
mais raté de me casser les couilles sur
le plateau et ciao ville où je n'y avait
pas de chanter moi j'ai besoin d'amour
entre
[Musique]
c'est un truc de fou
thibault in shape reste humble reste
humble bâtiment est ce que ça a très
très bien merci beaucoup je connaissais
pas mais par contre je cherche un coach
sportif donc vous pouvez pas nous faire
une démonstration des pompes sur une
main bien sûr on pense à une avec moi ou
alors moi je crois sans rigoler j'aime
bien me suis pété le point je comprends
tout à fait chéri mais bien ceux ci
c'est très simple on se met au sol on
prend les smarties tu prend l'espace à
grasse comme ceux ci a way up et malongo
c'est beau mais le voilà non mais c'est
ou faux pas non c'est tranquille barredo
c'est rock'n roll y arriver tout le
monde peut y arriver alors pas tout le
monde à tous comment ça je capte bien
vous laisser aller
les imériens ont changé tenir un peu
près tout seul le pec au sol base
arrière
la negafa conseil
[Rires]
mais qui sait qu m'angoisser ce soir
quotidien il faut y aller doucement des
frites cadre du sport tous les jours
forcément non franchement après tout
c'est quoi mais pas quand même beaucoup
de joueurs vous c'est ainsi franchement
si tu faisais pas la pole mais moi je
pense que je ferai en kg 150 km
mais moi mais je tenais je suis
l'outremangeur vous pouvez à condition
voilà d'heureux de demain refaire du
sport à fond et que vos grilles étaient
serrés là mais c'est pas par jean michel
aulas de réponse alors tarte à la crème
ou burger est ce que vous la petite a
dit ça j'irais tarte à la crème c'est
peut-être parce que vous croyez vous
voulez pas mardi tarte à la crème moins
calorique de l'homme de rien ouais je
pense vous êtes sûr non vous l'avez dit
oui regardez-le indices
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
il
m
[Applaudissements]
j
j'ai même envie de la fajeolle oui alors
il a mis la vie je ne sais pas répond à
miami je sais pas je vais l'appeler tout
de suite j'ai après deux chansons
6h02 - valeo pas je vais me frémaux b2o
voilà vous avez franck gastambide hausse
in the paint on aimerait bien sûr franck
gastambide hormis la garde aussi mais
c'est vrai que booba c'est moins évident
mais c'est vrai que je les adore voilà
c'est avec qui à chaque fois que je
demande un truc il est présent alors des
lois et répond ça va mon frérot d'amour
je disais que je t'aimais je disais que
je t'aimais dans l'émission j'irai que
j'étais comme un ouf parce que ce soit
ton nouveau single 5 g qui sort sur les
plateformes
ça va mon frère tu es bien mes amis à
mes abalo à gaumont ses patrons pas
parce qu apparemment ça va être
by donnant le président mais sous thèmes
boutard et je voulais te dire un truc
j'ai pas encore écouté mon single 5g
l'attend ce soir je t'explique à midi je
crois que je crois qu'une surprise de
dons plus je sais je sais il paraît il
mais il n'a pas voulu me dire ce que
c'était il est vrai qu'à une petite
surprise à skis puis une petite surprise
pour moi dedans rouget
je voulais te dire que je t'aime
vraiment fort et je disais tu es un gars
à chaque fois que l'appel et c1 était
vraiment réalité vraiment fait partie de
mes gars sur x factor parce que à chaque
fois que j'ai besoin de toi que j'ai
besoin d'un truc un conseil un truc tu
me réponds toujours tu es toujours là tu
sais que je t'aime fort
[Musique]